let's go to the we're gonna try again
with nine one nine let's go to our
caller from the nine one nine area code
I hope you can hear me let us know who
you are where you're calling from ah
c919 is not working again I feel like it
is not our phone I feel like it is the
909 phone what's the definition of
insanity David doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting different
results I guess okay let's try our
caller from the eight four seven area
code caller from eight four seven hello
hello who's this this is Steve Steve
what's on your mind today I had a
question about all the sexual harassment
claims coming out against people and me
yes in public go ahead yeah my quest my
question is um it seems a little odd
that all these harassment allegations
are coming out against people in the
quote-unquote liberal mainstream media
and when we know that their sexual
harassment in every part of society but
it seems that a disproportionate amount
of these allegations are coming out
against liberal TV news anchors and
other public figures giving everything
we know about rampant sexual harassment
in place in other places like Fox News
and just everywhere in society it seems
a little odd that it's just all coming
out against liberal public figures at
that time to me it seems especially to
be coming out against people who have
come out against Trump and I'm just
wondering if there's if that seems odd
to you or if there if it's just just
crazy break it down because I want to
think think through this critically
right so first and foremost is it true
that they're mostly liberals that that
are being accused I mean Charlie Rose is
he liberal he's like a super corporatist
he's been working with coca-cola and
like a spokesperson for big corporations
for a really long time I mean I guess
maybe he's liberal but I don't I don't
really know I don't know what Matt
Lauer's politics are at all I guess he
is he known to be a liberal well I guess
it's not
much liberal people people that have
come out against Trump many of whom
happen to be liberal but not always you
know I mean listen here's the problem
with making an assessment like that
let's for a second let's grant that
you're right Steve let's say it's
overwhelmingly liberals that are being a
key or people who are against Trump that
are being accused of sexual harassment
is it possible that the reason we're
hearing more about allegations against
liberals than conservatives is because
both the liberal harasser and liberal
victim are in an environment which by
virtue of being liberal is a better
environment for them to say hey here's
what happened to me right so there might
be other factors that are creating a
sort of self-selection bias I'm just
speaking out loud here right I don't
know the end yeah I know that microphone
yeah I so I think I think it's one Plex
than that I just don't know if I buy the
premise to because yes I know this was a
year or two ago but take a look at what
all started this right Roger Ailes Bill
O'Reilly know more if you go outside of
the media realms yeah so I it may not
even be true that they're mostly liberal
or anti Trump aside I'd have to think
about right you know I I would be the
first to point out if I thought that
there was any kind of concerted effort
or conspiracy to do X Y or Z and I'm
right now I'm just not seeing any
evidence of that
right right yeah all right there are
Steve I'm sorry thank okay thanks
Marshalls calling Steve thank you David
right very good
interesting question I just I'm not
afraid of the topic I just don't think
it's backed by the by the data right now